I need strong arms for this I don't
think I use much force the work is hard
and the Sun here in southern chile is
harsh but easily no kaya
really throws her back into it she's a
Mapuche Chile's largest indigenous
ethnic group she's been fighting for the
rights of her people for years she feels
they're being violated even in
modern-day Chile well she had me one
when I was 15 or 16 years old my father
said that in 20 to 30 years a lot of
Mapuche would rise up and you can see
just that happening there are a lot of
young people who are fighting for the
survival of our people in this country
they're fighting for the recognition of
their language their ethnicity but above
all for their ancestral lands land that
the Chilean government took away from
their ancestors in the 19th century
using brute force a large part of their
land was given to the European
immigrants now Mapuche activists have
occupied the land in an effort to get it
back
Jerrica young man the government wants
to silence us we're only an ethnic
minority and there are Mapuche who are
satisfied with what the government has
given us but we've decided to join what
I call an honorable struggle by
occupying land were fighting for the
reclamation of our entire territory
recupera sue so territorial the Mapuches
relationship to land to the earth is a
fundamental part of their cultural
identity the Mapuche have been farming
for millennia they feel uprooted without
land he Selena paya often comes here
from the capital Santiago in order to
help in the fields but she also brings
donations from the city since the
Mapuche
can survive on what they earn from
farming this farm is also on occupied
land the owner has withdrawn and appears
to be tolerating the squatters but the
calm is deceptive the situation could
shift at any time with police arresting
the people here even on Pine N and his
wife maria jose lingo p have decided to
take that risk
they say that acts of civil disobedience
like this are the only way for them
approach a to achieve anything in chile
the family and Halina gather in the
evening and discussed the latest news
there have been clashes between Mapuche
and the police not far from here the
police are infamous for their harsh
crackdowns maria jose is worried about
her family and me and oh mewing i'm
afraid of the psychological damage that
my children might suffer work grown-ups
and we know all about repression at the
hands of the police the children yes I'm
scared I'm scared of what could happen
to my children nothing what already is a
lucky boy pasar kamijo
Freddy Marie leo is also one of the
squatters he takes us into the so-called
red zone where the land conflict is
especially acute
Baumer opposite pole up edema we're now
driving through P Deema there's a
military base here for the Chilean
police which is prepared for any
situation that might arise in the
occupying communities capo de dentro la
comida en residencia some 170 police
officers are stationed behind the walls
Marie Leo explains that they're supposed
to protect the forestry companies
against squatters we're not allowed to
shoot footage there at just 23 years old
Freddy Maurizio is already his community
spokesman the massive police presence
makes him even more determined led to a
cinema bûche as Mapuche with the goal of
reclaiming our territory we are prepared
to face anything the government
confronts us with in confronting our
lives are in constant danger so we have
to defend ourselves
for this we use sticks fists and stones
or anything we can use to drive off the
police so I got it up what you see alien
SEMA and firearms no no no no we fight
hand-to-hand here on our territory it's
only the police who use firearms momento
en nuestro de retour en la policia they
work in the forest that on paper at
least belongs to one of Chile's two
biggest forestry companies since the
occupation started Marie Leo's community
has been making a living from selling
lumber they hope the government will
reach an agreement with the timber
company and hand the land over to them
the sale of eucalyptus wood is only
meant as a temporary money earner
tenemos que cigar 8a okay we have to
fill the eucalyptus trees here and
restore the natural flow of water that
once existed here
Lorena and Toma and today we can work
this land display para puede trabajar lo
nuevamente tenemos que singular we'll
need to put a lot of effort into
removing all the tree stumps and then
farming the land here or planting native
trees here again lo que vou kena divo ii
Celina pile is back in Santiago de Chile
where she was born the 43 year olds
parents had to leave the rural South
since there wasn't enough land available
for them to make a living as farmers but
life in the city wasn't much easier in
c-130 I don't listen when our parents
arrived in Santiago to find work here
the women had to take whatever jobs they
could find and that was as housekeepers
what that it don't live it they were
locked up and had to work without breaks
or days off le livre
her parents experiences inspired his
Alena to become an activist even today
the Mapuche face discrimination in the
city she tells us that most live in poor
neighborhoods working under paid jobs
and that the illiteracy rate among the
Mapuche is twice as high as in the rest
of the population
he's Elina works as a seamstress and
earns money selling Mapuche flags would
she consider moving back to the
countryside yep oh yeah oh no Sonia
should you dream of going back to your
community but it's not possible right
there's not enough land for us to return
even though that would be best for all
Mapuche so she continues her fight for
greater indigenous rights from Santiago
the Chilean government has recently
admitted it has what it called a
historic debt to the indigenous
population even Maria Fernanda Viegas
the Social Affairs Minister has spoken
of that debt but she has no sympathy for
the land occupations by the Mapuche
communities beseemeth each okay if they
wanna so see we have the rule of law
here and we welcome any steps aimed at
sitting together and engaging in
dialogue but we do not accept the use of
violence in order to assert alleged
interests interests that by the way
aren't even supported by all the Mapuche
people I'm convinced that the Mapuche
are a people of peace who are striving
to claim their rights and opportunities
equal to EI the government of President
Michelle Bachelet is planning to set up
a Ministry of Indigenous Affairs
elimedia gave them only support with
that we are opening a door with the
Ministry of Indigenous Affairs we are
striving for real solutions and we will
also be able to solve the question of
land ownership on the whole
the ministry will help bring the
government and the Mapuche communities
together mejora no el acercamiento en el
estado y la commune da but y Celina paya
doesn't believe that it's Wednesday
evening time for a weekly meeting of the
mapuche supporters group e Selina has
been attending them since she was a
teenager while many other interest
groups want to cooperate with the new
ministry ISA Lena and her fellow
campaigners don't trust the official
promises even though the government has
been starting to return land to the
Mapuche they say that's taking too long
and is too bureaucratic well um a pooch
a yeah but the Mapuche people have
learned that Chilean politics is not a
good tool for achieving what we want it
is important to get involved politically
but our people have their own way their
own political strategies their own
leaders yeah and that's why we've
remained to this day of people willing
to fight and we will remain that my mar
29 and the next day that fight takes the
form of baking soap IPS a Salinas group
is selling them for more fundraising
this time they're looking to collect
money to buy school supplies for
children in the occupied areas no won't
come fast enough they say a prayer for
assistance in their struggle we're only
allowed to record that from a distance
won't it be the fool we asked our
ancestors our grandfathers our parents
to accompany and support us in whatever
may come so we may be successful it's
not about the desires of individuals but
about the desires of an entire people
part of the benefit event is pileinn a
traditional Mapuche game
the idea is that the players meet and
get to know each other and become
friends through that that's the
intention
latency ISA Lina hopes that getting to
know each other will also promote
understanding for their struggle for
land and rights she knows her group's
maximum demands and land occupations
have little chance of success and may
even hinder a lasting conciliation with
the government but she like many others
doesn't want to give in me sueño Parra
me as a mapache I have a dream I want my
people to move forward with their heads
held high for us to continue to live as
proudly as we've done all this time
Selena Pyle is certain that if the
Mapuche don't get back the majority of
their ancestral lands then more of them
will have to move to the cities and then
she fears their culture which is so
closely bound to the soil will die out
completely